>>> ON THIS WEEK'S EPISODE OF
THE PODCAST "ALL THERE IS WITH
ANDERSON COOPER," ANDERSON LOOKS
AT GRIEF AND TALKS ABOUT THE
PROCESS OF SLOWLY LOSING HIS
BELOVED NANNY TO ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE.
>> WATCHING HER DECLINE,
WATCHING ALL THE DREAMS I HAD OF
GIVING HER A HOUSE OR HAVING HER
LIVE WITH ME WHEN I HAD KIDS ONE
DAY, WATCHING ALL THAT DISAPPEAR
WAS -- IT WAS LIKING IN I EVER
EXPERIENCED.
IT WAS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
GRIEF.
DIFFERENT THAN MY MOM.
DIFFERENT THAN MY DAD.
DIFFERENT THAN MY BROTHER.
AND AFTER A TIME MAY STOPPED
SPEAKING WORDS.
WHEN I VISIT, SHE STILL KNEW WHO
I WAS BUT SHE WOULD OPEN HER
MOUTH AND THE ONLY SOUND THAT
CAME OUT WAS A SINGLE NOTE, LIKE
SHE WAS SINGING.
AAHHHH.
>> AND ANDERSON IS WITH US NOW
ALONG WITH SEBASTIAN WHO WE'RE
SO HAPPY TO HAVE HIM COME BACK
AGAIN WITH US.
HI, BUDDY.
ANDERSON, IT'S SO MOVING.
AND I KNOW SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE
LOST SOMEONE SLOWLY LIKE THIS OR
GOING TO APPRECIATE YOU GIVING
VOICE TO THIS PROCESS FOR THEM.
CAN YOU TALK TO US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THIS CONCEPT OF
ANTICIPATORY GRIEF?
>> YEAH.
I NEVER HEARD THE TERM BEFORE.
AND A FILMMAKER WHO I
INTERVIEWED IN THIS EPISODE OF
THE PODCAST, SHE'S ONE WHO
MENTIONED IT IN AN INCREDIBLE
FILM ABOUT HER FATHER.
SHE LOST HER MOM TO ALZHEIMER'S
IN 2007.
HER FATHER NOW STRUGGLES WITH
DEMENTIA.
BUT THIS IDEA OF ANYONE THAT
LOST SOMEONE TO ALZHEIMER'S OR
DEALING WITH THAT OR ANY
TERMINAL ILLNESS, IT'S THE IDEA
OF, YOU KNOW, SEEING THE GRADUAL
DECLINE, THE DISAPPEARANCE OF
SOMEBODY BEFORE YOUR EYES AND
ANTICIPATINGING WHAT IS TO COME.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO
NECESSARILY GET ANY BETTER.
IT'S GOING TO BE THIS DRAWN OUT
THING.
SO YOU'RE ALREADY ANTICIPATING
THEIR DEATH, YOU'RE ANTICIPATING
BEING WITHOUT THEM IN YOUR LIFE
YET THEY'RE STILL THERE IN FRONT
OF YOU.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH, AND IT'S
NICE WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IT
AND TO KNOW THAT YOU ARE NOT THE
FIRST PERSON WHO HAS GONE DOWN
THIS ROAD.
>> YOU KNOW, I NEVER HEARD THAT
CONCEPT EITHER, UNTIL YOU
MENTIONED IT.
SORT OF LIKE THE HORROR MOVIE
WHERE IT'S NOT THE LOUD NOISE
THAT IS THE WORST.
IT'S KNOWING WHAT'S TO COME THAT
TEARS YOU UP INSIDE.
WE HAVE A CLIP OF YOUR
CONVERSATION WITH THE FILMMAKER.
>> ONE OF THE CLASSIC STORIES I
TELL IS HIM WAKING UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT EXTREMELY
WORRIED THAT THERE'S A PATIENT
DOWNSTAIRS.
I CAN'T CONVINCE HIM THAT THE
PATIENT IS NOT THERE.
THEN I GO DOWNSTAIRS WITH HIM.
THEN HE LOOKS AROUND, HE'S LIKE,
THERE'S NO PATIENT.
OH, YOU WERE RIGHT.
SHE SAYS, IT MUST BE INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TO WATCH YOUR FATHER
LOSE HIS MIND.
>> SO HE HAD THE SELF-AWARENESS
OF WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
>> YES, THAT WOULD GO IN AND
OUT.
WHEN IT'S IN, IT'S LIKE A KNIFE
IF YOUR HEART.
>> ANDERSON, YOU SAID ONE OF THE
REASONS SHE WAS SO GREAT TO TALK
TO IS BECAUSE SHE TALKED TO YOU
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF BEING
ABLE TO GET TO KNOW SOMEONE EVEN
AFTER THEY DIE.
WHAT DOES SHE MEAN BY THAT?
>> THIS IS A CONCEPT TO ME WHICH
KIND OF BLEW MY MIND.
I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT AND
CAN GIVE HOPE TO SO MANY PEOPLE.
IT'S THIS IDEA THAT YOUR
RELATIONSHIP -- DEATH IS NOT THE
END OF YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THAT PERSON.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS LIKE TOO,
SORT OF OUT THERE.
BUT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PERSON WHO
HAS DIED.
I CONTINUE TO HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THIS NANNY I
HAD FOR 15 YEARS, WHO WAS LIKE A
MOTHER TO ME, AS CLOSE TO ME AS
MY MOM AND MY DAD.
I STAYED INVOLVED IN HER LIFE
FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE EVEN
AFTER SHE WAS NO LONGER MY
NANNY.
HAVING CHILDREN, HAVING MY KIDS,
I UNDERSTAND MAY IN A DIFFERENT
WAY THAN I DID BEFORE.
I KNOW WHAT SHE WAS DOING WHEN
SHE WAS CARING FOR ME.
I SEE HER IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
AND KIRSTEN WAS TALKING ABOUT
THAT, AND I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT IDEA THAT YOU
CAN GET TO KNOW SOMEBODY -- EVEN
AFTER THEY'RE GONE, YOU CAN GET
TO KNOW THEM IN A DEEPER WAY BY
READING SOMETHING THEY WROTE OR
GOING THROUGH THEIR THINGS OR AS
YOU BECOME -- AS I BECOME A
55-YEAR-OLD MAN, I CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT MY MOM WENT
THROUGH WHEN SHE LOST HER
HUSBAND, MY DAD, WHEN SHE WAS
50.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THINGS AS A
PARENT ABOUT MY PARENTS THAT I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND BEFORE.
SO EVEN THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER
PRESENT, THEY'RE STILL VERY
PRESENT IN YOUR LIFE AND YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM EVOLVES.
TO ME THAT'S A REALLY HOPEFUL
THING BECAUSE IT MEANS THAT THAT
LOVE THAT YOU HAVE, THAT BOND
THAT YOU HAVE, IT'S OBVIOUSLY
DIFFERENT THAN IF THEY WERE
HERE.
BUT YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THEM IN A
NEW OR DEEPER WAY.
>> ANDERSON, WHAT KIND OF
REACTION HAVE YOU BEEN GETTING
TO THIS INCREDIBLE SERIES?
>> IT'S BEEN REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY.
IT'S BEEN OVERWHELMING.
I'VE RECEIVED I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY DIRECT MESSAGES FROM
PEOPLE ON INSTAGRAM WHICH IS
GENERALLY THE WAY I COMMUNICATE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT'S INCREDIBLY DEEP MESSAGES
FROM PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THE
LOSSES THEY'VE EXPERIENCED AND
HOW THEY'VE DEALT WITH IT AND
WHAT THEY'RE TAKING FROM THE
PODCAST AND IDEAS FOR THE
PODCAST.
THERE'S AN OCEAN OF LOSS AND AN
OCEAN OF GRIEF.
THIS IS THE MOST COMMON OF HUMAN
EXPERIENCES.
WE ALL TALK ABOUT BIRTH AND TALK
ABOUT THAT FREELY.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT DEATH AND
LOSS.
I THINK THIS IS A CONVERSATION A
LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
BECAUSE NOT HAVING IT DOESN'T
MAKE IT GO AWAY.
NOT HAVING IT ONLY MAKES YOU
FEEL MORE LONELY AND ISOLATED AS
I'VE FELT FOR A LONG TIME.
>> SO TRUE.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING, ANDERSON.
I'M SO GLAD WE CAN TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THIS.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING TIME WITH
US.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> AND SEBASTIAN, AS ALWAYS, SEE
YOU LATER BUD.
HE'S SO COOL ABOUT THIS ALWAYS.
YOU CAN BE SURE TO CHECK OUT THE
LATEST EPISODE OF "ALL THERE IS"
AVAILABLE